[Musique]
je suis sa taille et une point haut en
bas avec un gros bloc de verre c'est le
seul morceau les russes comme du monde
mais donc comme c'était très difficile
qu'ils m'ont pas taillables j'ai été
acheté des pointes pointe à callière les
suivants la boutique du petit point
alors je suis a semblé qu'une une patte
époxy et puis j'ai redonné ensuite géré
sculpté de dans le l'effet de deux cas
sur une fois sculpter les bases et
simplement coulé en silicone des moules
alors une fois cool et j'ai pu avoir des
pointes à résine comme ça et puis sur
lequel je donner une patine très la plus
précise possible en fin de compte on
voit ici la cannelure qui lui prenait
place chaque bord il fallait très très
habile pour russie avec une pierre venir
détacher ce morceau là c'est assez
c'est fascinant
[Musique]